playing stan from i.t
what is it
italy
or information technology
okay
hey eric is the stream going on youtube
uh probably
at the very least it will go on my extra
channel
but maybe i could just throw it on my
main channel too
i think there's been some good content
so far
okay so i'm playing a knight's tango
um the point of knight c6 was to prepare
e5 so if knight c3 i would have played
e5
against knight f3
i switch up the plan a little bit
and white's playing actually uh
very nicely
to prevent like all of the things i want
to do because now i can't really develop
my bishop i don't want to play bishop d6
so this is where i change plans
and i'm going to encounter the bishop
to
[Music]
g7
and this is actually still prep for me
also if you do end up taking my
challenge there's a new stafford line i
have in the magical line i dubbed the
rostline of the staff at gambit okay
now i feel
i feel intrigued
i'm pretty sure we're still following uh
a game like a very high level game
uh between verouncobian and fabiano
caruana
they played a few years ago in the pro
chess league
and had like almost exact same position
[Music]
but i'm pretty sure var just played
knight c3
and d5
d5 will play knight d7
oh this is rated blitz
yes after the pawn took the file opened
and white was threatening to take
so bishop g7 defends the rook so this
pawn isn't pinned and it is nice having
the bishop hair here
i feel a little bit conflicted here
because one part of me really wants to
play e5
and just close the center and then go
for f5
but e5 just makes my bishop sad
so maybe i'll just play knight g6
keep the tension
maybe put the queen on e7
and then perhaps use the e5 square for
the knight
i'm debating bishop d7
[Music]
i might play a6 actually
just kind of a waiting move
so i'm curious which side white swimming
castle
and then i'll know where to attack
oh it's not castling
now wait's playing a good game for the
reading
and bishop d7 here
it was considering 95 after it takes
tigger's bishop h5 check
which is a little bit unpleasant
now i could take and then play this in
f5
it doesn't look so great though
let me queen f6
just target the knight
it looks a little bit strange but uh
white's gonna have to
[Music]
figure out what to do with this knight
yeah so in the ocobian caruana game a
caruana did fiend caddo the liked bishop
but var didn't push d5 so early
i think here with d5
included this bishop doesn't want to
stare at the pawn chain
if anything i should just keep the
bishop back
and then wait until this diagonal opens
yeah maybe a bishop d7 here
wow
[Music]
i think this is the first sign of white
being generous to me
probably just miscounted the number of
attackers
the rook is so cool like a mini castle
[Music]
also the night is so cool
it's like a miniature pony
okay
getting what i want
there's some
okay not right now of course but
maybe someday later
bishop a4
i'm gonna keep being aggressive
knife f4
what's your favorite chess piece
it really depends on the position
but probably the pony
white has everything defended
i'm realizing night of one might be some
idea for whites
so i feel kind of wrong playing this
because it does shut down my bishop but
it does
just strengthen my setup
and then i have the idea later playing
h5 and bishop h6
and then target the
other diagonal
oh what's my favorite checkers piece
and it's got to be the king
but checkers you don't start with a king
[Music]
what do you call checkers pieces you
just call them a piece
not sure if they have a name
oh we have a poll going
i didn't see the poll
okay here's
some really special data
wait is my queen trapped
oh no
how'd my queen get trapped
uh oh
i'm in trouble
[Music]
my queen's just trapped
how'd that happen
i can't move to f2
finally caught another stream i should
turn on notifications
hey good catch
but you're joining at a slightly tragic
time
i'm in big trouble here
i think this is my best
nothing's good though
uh
okay let's take the bishop
i got the focus here
now
my favorite piece is definitely this
horsey
i don't no longer have a queen
maybe i should have given my queen more
respect
and rook b8
i could castle queenside too
it looks wrong but
i connect the rooks
and i defend the pawn
[Music]
okay i'd like to make a prediction that
someday this horsey is going to fork the
king and the queen
someday
might not be today
but maybe tomorrow
um
okay so it's five plus three
i do have an outside pass pawn
yeah that's scary
i have to take
and this is not at all what i want
um
i didn't see this coming until
until i had v5
wow
i got a rosin trophy for that too
got the pawn mate
good game
man stan from i.t played like a really
good game
[Music]
i was in
really big trouble there
oh man
[Music]
yeah i think here if if white plays king
a4 first
then b5 isn't mating
and knight d4 is a little bit slow
ftw
okay we'll get to the rostline very soon
man what a game
i really thought that we were gonna get
a situation wrong my pieces didn't like
they would all be like out of play on
the second rank
but they turned out to be really useful
wow looks like i actually joined at a
great time to witness such a comeback
yeah this is my first like real queen
blender
the first game of the stream i uh i had
like a nice oh no my queen trap
but this was actual oh no my queen